en este vídeo vamos a seguir con la idea
de simplificación de que existe un gen
que codifica para el color de ojos y que
sólo hay dos variantes la variante
dominante como vimos en el vídeo pasado
le pusimos p mayúscula y bueno esta
variante codifica para los ojos de color
café entonces voy a poner aquí café y
tenemos otra variante recuerdas la
variante de minúscula be minúscula que
codifica para los ojos de color azul así
que lo voy a poner aquí ojos de color
azul si uno de tus alelos es esta vez
mayúscula como es una variante dominante
tendrás los ojos cafés y la única manera
de tener los ojos azules es ser el homo
cigoto para el alelo recesivo minúscula
de minúscula ahora digamos que tenemos
una población bastante grande una
población que cumple con todos los
supuestos del equilibrio de hardy
weisberg y digamos que observamos que la
población tienen
y el 9 por ciento el 9 por ciento de las
personas tienen los ojos azules tienen
en ojos azules azules y observa que
ahora estamos hablando del fenotipo tú
puedes observar que tiene los ojos
azules bueno aparte de esto podemos
imaginarnos cuánto vale p y recuerda que
p
era la frecuencia con la que observamos
el alelo dominante el alelo be mayúscula
podemos imaginarnos cuánto vale esta p y
bueno ya con esto también podemos saber
podemos obtener cuánto valía q y
recuerda que era la frecuencia del alelo
recesivo podemos también averiguar
cuánto vale q así que te invito que te
tengas en este momento en vídeo y
basándote en lo que vimos en el vídeo
pasado sobre la ecuación de hadi bakhsh
ver pienses en cuanto vale pn y cuánto
vale con bien pues repasemos la ecuación
dejar divines ver que vimos en el vídeo
anterior y gracias los siguientes
recuerdas la ecuación dice que p
cuadrada p cuadrada
dos veces
que multiplica a su vez aquí déjame
ponerlo así dos veces p por q y a esto
le sumamos un cuadrado si a esto le
sumamos q cuadrada esto iba a ser
exactamente igual que 1
el cuadrado de la frecuencia dominante
más dos veces la frecuencia del alelo
dominante por la frecuencia del alelo
recesivo más el cuadrado de la
frecuencia del alelo recesivo esto es
igual a 1 y como vimos en el vídeo
anterior esto proviene de la idea de que
p más q es igual a 1 es decir existe 100
por ciento de probabilidad de que al
escoger un alelo al azar nos dé una de
estas dos variantes en fin regresando al
problema cuando decimos que el 9% tiene
los ojos azules que significa bueno la
única manera de obtener ojos azules es
que tu genotipo sea el homo cigoto
recesivo para este gen b minúscula b
minúscula porque recuerda que si tienes
un ave mayúscula entonces tendrás los
ojos cafés éste era el alelo dominante
entonces podemos decir que el 9% de la
población también tiene este genotipo b
minúscula b minúscula o podemos decir
que la frecuencia de este genotipo en la
boca
acción es un 9 por ciento pero como ya
vimos eso es exactamente lo que
significa este término de aquí q
cuadrada o cuadrada es la probabilidad
de obtener dos alelos recesivos en tu
población siquiera la probabilidad de
obtener un alelo recesivo en tu
población bueno pues que guardara que es
lo mismo que q por q es lo mismo que
tener la probabilidad de obtener dos
alelos recesivos en tu población y esa
probabilidad será del 9 por ciento así
que déjame ponerlo aquí q cuadrada va a
ser lo mismo que 9 % que es lo mismo que
tenemos aquí este sería un 9 por ciento
o dicho de otra manera si lo escribimos
como decimal
esto me quedaría como 0.09
entonces si ya tenemos aquí cuadrada
podemos despejar de una manera muy
sencilla y así obtener el valor de q q
cuadrada y déjame escribirlo en su forma
decimal o cuadrada de 0.09 y esto quiere
decir que entonces el valor de q es la
raíz cuadrada de 0.09 lo cual es lo
mismo que 0.3 o el 30% de nuestra
población y así de fácil y así de
sencillo fuimos capaces de obtener a cu
cú que es la frecuencia del alelo
recesivo va a ser lo mismo que el 30% si
lo quieres ver como porcentaje es decir
que si estuvieras viendo los alelos en
la población el 30 por ciento sería el
alelo recesivo con la variante recesiva
y bueno basándonos en esto podemos saber
el porcentaje que codifica para la
variante dominante el resto de los
alelos
el alelo dominante claro suponiendo que
solamente tenemos dos variantes p más q
es igual al 100% y ya sabemos que el 30%
codifica para la variante recesiva
entonces p más q debe de ser igual a 1 o
al 100% recuerdas por lo tanto en la
frecuencia con la que tengo el alelo
dominante debe ser igual al resto es
decir 70 por ciento 70% y ya con esto
podemos excavar un poco más y pensar
cuánto vale p cuadrada p cuadradas será
bueno pues el 70% al cuadrado estás de
acuerdo es decir 0.7 esto elevado al
cuadrado y si lo hacemos nos va a dar un
0.41
y de esta ecuación tan simple están
surgiendo bastantes resultados a partir
de esta información que vimos ahora
somos capaces de decir que el 49% de la
población tiene el genotipo b mayúscula
b mayúscula es decir tenemos un genotipo
homocigotos dominante y bueno ya con
esto podemos obtener el valor de este
término que nos falta dos veces pei por
q esto es lo mismo que toman 2 2 2 que
multiplica a pep pero pepe valero 0.7
que multiplica a 0.7 que a su vez
multiplica a cu pero q vale 0.3 0.3 y
bueno cuanto es esto 2 por 0.7 por 0.3
0.7 por 0.3 0.21 por 2 me va a dar el
resultado de todo esto de qué es
0.42 esto nos dice que el 42% de la
población tendrá como genotipo b
mayúscula o minúscula y ahora observa
que el 49% de la población más el 42% de
la población más el 9% de la población
no sabe el 100 por ciento de la
población nos da 1
todo esto basándonos en lo que sabemos
de frecuencias alélicas y haciendo un
poco de suposiciones gracias a esto
podemos obtener más conocimiento acerca
de esta población y esto de hecho es muy
útil en la realidad cuando las personas
piensan no sé digamos en un alelo
recesivo que pueda causar algún tipo de
enfermedad basándose en los casos con
esta enfermedad
bueno las personas pueden preguntarse
qué porcentaje de la población es un
portador y ahora sabemos que hay
heterocigotos para esta enfermedad y
esto es muy útil para la vida real